[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships christina alice
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we take your questions at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five the call is free and some
say the advice is worth exactly what you
pay for it
matt is with us in albany new york hey
matt how are you
i'm good thanks for everything for
having me sure man what's up
so
i graduated from college one year ago
and uh hopefully i got a good job and
i'm about to pay off all my debt from it
uh but
uh as i pay off my debt i kind of feel
guilty about how much my parents
contributed to paying for my college and
i want to pay them back except i'm not
exactly sure
where it should kind of fit into my kind
of baby steps and then
the best way to go about paying them
both back is if my parents are divorced
and they uh contributed different
amounts so i don't know if you guys help
me out with that
is there an expectation for you to pay
them back like is it something where
they expect it or is it something you
just want to do out of generosity
uh
no they don't expect it there's never an
agreement i just i feel
i feel like i want to do it and i have
two younger siblings going about to go
into college and i can tell they're
really stressed about it and i feel like
uh i i feel kind of bad for uh i feel
like i feel like they paid all the money
a lot of the money that they had saved
up for me and i want to help my siblings
out too i guess
that's very kind to you what other debt
you had you said you're about to pay off
the rest of your debt
uh it's all just federal loans um
in a matter like in a week or two i'll
have all the money to pay that off
completely so it's basically a
basically a baby step too
how much money are we talking about with
your mom and dad
uh so my mom paid in about 50 and my dad
paid in about 15. okay and you make what
now
uh 75
okay all right
well there's nothing morally wrong with
what you're doing there's no moral
uh or legal
obligation for what you're talking about
doing you understand that
right right okay and so as long you know
that does make it what christina said
that it makes it an act of generosity
on your part
um i don't like that you use the word
guilty
because you're not guilty
i'm a dad who paid for my kids college
and i'm not i have no desire for them to
feel guilty about that
it's something i did as a parent i was
able to do it i did it it's done
your your little brothers and sisters
your siblings uh that are going to
school have they got the money to send
them
uh
i
they um i i guess that's another part i
like i don't know like the exact numbers
all their financial
the whole financial situation but i know
like there's a there's a lot of stress
there's a lot of discussion about it and
so they had a college fund for you or
they are they cash flowed you
uh okay like basically cash flowing me i
guess okay and now they're they're
struggling with i think there's a little
save so why are they struggling with
cash flowing the next one
uh i i mean
i guess it kind of comes down i don't
know the exact situation
yeah i don't know the other numbers i
feel like a little awkward like asking
for my parents like financial
information but
okay yeah
um
now this
you're doing this blind
okay and blind's not good
um you have a sense
in the air that there's stress and that
may they may not have enough money but
you don't really have that information
and that added with your gratitude for
them taking care of you and the
awkward weirdness of them doing it
through a divorced process
that that also is in the air and that's
screwy right and awkward
um and so you've got all this stuff
going on you got this whole this this
whole gumbo this whole soup here that
you're stirring up but we don't even
know what the ingredients are so if you
want to be generous you need to be
generous with knowledge
and so i would sit down with your mom
have a cup of coffee and go this is what
i'm feeling
now tell me where you are with your
finances
because i i'm kind of thinking i may
need to help you out so that you can
help the siblings out
tell me what's going on
and and if she says look i told you i
was paying for college i'm in good shape
shut up
then shut up and move on if she says
yeah i'm freaking out i don't know what
i'm going to do then you may want to do
this generous move if you want to okay
and have the same conversation with your
dad but let's let's have uh
all the cards of the relationship and
the situation face up on the table so
that everybody them and you all know
what's going on here and by the way tell
your mom that you're having the same
conversation with your dad and your dad
you're having the same conversation with
your mom there's no secrets here there's
no hidden corners there's no darkness
that shadows that things are hiding
under it's all out in the light and then
the answer will be very very plain as to
what you're supposed to do
if your suspicions are confirmed and you
want to go ahead and you do it all from
knowledge
i'm with you go do it i would not just
write checks into a blind crappy
situation and you don't know what's
going on
that makes sense
yeah and it's good for the relationship
too because you're manning up
you're looking at your mom and going hey
i'm like a grown man and stuff and i'm
making 75k
i can help in this situation she goes no
i got a million dollars over here i
never told you about
you know
but she just generally she just
generally is a person who worries or
frets you know i don't know i don't know
i don't know what you're going to find
out but at a minimum you're going to
find out more than you know now
well the other way you can be generous
with knowledge is
you can also help your siblings like you
can help them
work through the logistics of going to
college so of course it's great if your
parents can cash flow college but the
kids can also work they can win
scholarships they can get tuition
assistance programs there's all sorts of
ways to graduate debt-free so if there
is an actual money issue and your
parents don't have the money to pay for
your siblings college perhaps then you
can step in as a mentor you sound like
you have an excellent head on your
shoulders you're doing well financially
you can step in and mentor your siblings
to figure out how to pay for college
themselves and also if you move on to
baby steps you know get your fully
funded emergency fund get into four
through six if you have some extra
perhaps you can help your siblings
financially but i think there's a lot of
ways to look at this yeah and it can be
both you can mentor them and write some
checks into mom and dad if you find all
this out so let but let's not just go
i kind of have this vague sense of guilt
like i got money and they're not and
they don't have it and the kids are gone
you know and then i'm just gonna start
writing no i don't write checks into
blind funds homebrew checks into blind
situations and it's not it's it's a good
relationally cleaning thing to have this
conversation it's going to be it's going
to be beautiful
so and you're a good dude man that's a
great heart on your shoulder a great
heart a head on your shoulders as you
said heart and everything the whole
somebody who actually wants to do this
is that that's just cool yeah good on
you for getting ready to pay off the
rest of your student loans like that
sounds amazing you said next week you're
going to be able to pay everything off
so we're really proud of you that's
incredible yeah making more money's ever
made in his life got out of college
living the dream and we're going to take
a 65 000
pit stop here and take care of mom and
dad if we want to
um or not
depending on what you find out you might
find out some
wonderful things you may find out some
things that are not so wonderful but
you're going to find out more than you
know now
and that's what you need to do this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why your mortgage plan because
they're committed to doing what's right
for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis number one best-selling
author ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer questions about your
life and your money that last young man
wanting to pay his mom and dad back for
having paid for his college
very very sweet um kind of a theme we
got rolling up here a little bit this
email came in
um and you want to read it yeah this
because it's pretty cool yeah it says my
name is gabriel i'm emily you all from
san antonio texas i graduated high
school in 2019 my father was the first
to go to college in the family he
graduated from texas a m my family have
been die hard fans ever since i was
lucky enough to get accepted to texas a
m but reluctantly turned down my dream
school i did so because i knew i was on
my own when it came to paying for
college
me wanting to go to college without debt
was a huge driver so instead i stayed
home to save money
i went to a local community college then
transferred to utsa
still staying home i graduated a few
months ago in may of 2022. i graduated
in three years with no college credits
from high school i didn't take any
summers off but more than that i by
myself paid every dime of tuition and
fees with no scholarships i used the
money i earned from working at a grocery
store
because of where i worked i was lucky
enough during covid to always have a job
i'm sure you all get a lot of thank you
emails with more powerful stories but i
wanted to make sure y'all knew y'all had
an impact on mine i'm 21 years old
debt-free with a college degree
and just accepted a teaching job at a
public high school and i will soon go
back for my master's god willing one day
i will be a principal thank you all for
the work you do god bless i hope you're
a principal well there's principles
that'll be awesome we need teachers like
you what a stud what a stud what an
incredible story i love it
utsa for those of you that listening at
home don't know what that is university
of texas san antonio
and so um instead of being an aggie he
ended up being a longhorn but uh
just in case you're wondering but yeah
that's uh
and he's a teacher and he paid cash for
it yeah i love that he took every excuse
off the table so he you know didn't get
any scholarships so any excuse that man
i don't qualify for scholarships i don't
have a competitive resume well guess
what he didn't have scholarships he
didn't have money from his parents he
didn't have credits going in and he
still did it all working with a job at a
grocery store on his own like it can be
done i have to have a student loan or i
can't be a student gabriel says shut up
seriously
i mean that's beautiful yeah so it
amount it matters to see that's what
you should do
you know we're not against education
we're against stupid methods of becoming
educated
in stupid degrees that have no use
and no roi based on what you paid for
them so when you pay 250 000
at a famous college to become a
left-handed puppetry expert you're an
idiot you become a barista
with a 250 000
student loan debt don't do that stuff
and moms and dads don't let your kids do
that
grab them around the neck knock a noggin
on them do you know what that means pop
them on the head right just pop no
you're not doing that you're not going
250 000 in debt to say you went to
school somewhere famous that doesn't
mean a dad blame thing when you're out
here doing stuff where you went to
school will not get you a job at ramsey
we have 1200 employees we're hiring 300
people this year and we don't give a rip
where you went to school all we care is
did you actually learn something
and can you use that to make money can
you use that to justify your freaking
existence on my payroll that's how
employers think okay
and you know don't talk to me i have it
i mean
shut up can you do stuff
that's what matters can you do stuff
and education helps you do stuff you
need to be smart not against education
not doing zero post high school work of
any kind is a bad idea you need to do
something
it doesn't start
you can do an apprenticeship you can go
into a trade but all of those require
certifications and additional training
and everything else and so i don't care
if you want to be an electrician an hvac
a diesel mechanic or you want to be a
mechanical engineer or a brain
scientist you know i don't care what
you're doing but you need more training
after high school education is key to
winning but education has become stupid
and that's the irony in our culture it's
just the irony and this kid just reeks
of common sense right well and the thing
is is like you have got to look at your
situation your set of cards that you've
been dealt and then be strategic and
intentional like he looked at his
situation his family loved this certain
school but then he saw a community
college that he could go to possibly for
free or extremely cheap and then he
could transfer another to another great
school and he just made the most of his
situation so many people are going into
college and they see one route they see
their parents alma mater they see where
all their friends are going and they
think that this is the only way i have
to go this way and then they take out a
ton of student loans it was it's my
dream
you're gonna turn your dream into a
nightmare you goob
don't do that
don't don't it's my dream i mean these
people do not let someone select a
college because the trees on the campus
are pretty i've actually talked to 17
year olds at that i want to go there
because the campus is pretty that's
dumber than a rock
you do not want to do that that's
ridiculous it's a very short-sighted
dream it's like you know four years of
pretty buildings and nice trees and then
you get out of college and you can't
afford rent in a decent area or you
can't afford to buy a house i think we
figured out how we paid for those trees
oh my god
unbelievable yeah it's really what it is
so and you know christina is like a
walking testimony to this um you know
brief version of your story yeah so my
mom told me my freshman year of high
school that she didn't have the money to
pay for my college your mom was a widow
your dad died when you were seven yep
after a long and painful battle with
brain cancer and my mom she what she
didn't have in money she gave us the
motivation and drive to push forward she
really taught us that we could do
anything we set our minds to i still
look back and i'm like i don't know how
she got us so convinced that we could
just do anything she's an immigrant from
venezuela she grew up with nothing force
of nature is what she is
yeah so she just really told me to go
after it all throughout high school i
got super motivated to figure out what
it takes to win scholarships i did over
a thousand hours of community service i
built up my resume took up leadership
roles and then my senior year of high
school i treated the scholarship
application process like a part-time job
i just applied and applied and applied
and thankfully the effort it was worth
it it led me to win over a half a
million dollars in scholarships and go
to vanderbilt university for undergrad
and belmont for grad school completely
debt-free five hundred thousand dollars
worth
thank god okay
so i mean now you know you're unusually
bright kind of intimidatingly
but you and you got this incredible work
ethic and your mom is a force of nature
she didn't know she was not allowing you
to you didn't have a choice you were
gonna do this oh it wasn't like i choose
to sit down no you're doing it oh she's
going to she was on your house she was
on you there was no other gift to you
was not a a blank check
or encouragement to go get student loan
debt because we're poor people and we
don't have any money and so we can't go
to school and this is people like us and
she shouldn't play the victim card no
no quite the opposite quite the opposite
it was kind of funny because it's like
in hindsight i didn't really see any
other way like she gave me that
challenge and it was like all right
let's go let's do this like student
loans weren't an option i just was like
okay let's let's let's run let's go yeah
and so you know some of you moms and
dads are saving money for college and
you know you got a hundred thousand
bucks saved up or 150 000 bucks saved up
and junior walks in and tells you he's
going somewhere well yeah i got 150 000
reasons i'm gonna tell you what to do
junior you know i'm holding this check
hostage you're not going anywhere that
i'm releasing my money to
that i don't approve of and if it
involves you going into debt or taking
some dumb butt degree that is useless in
the real world we're not releasing this
money oh and by the way you're going to
continue to live a life that is honoring
to god in the process and say oh yeah
dave's a dinosaur he makes his kids
behave who knew you know they're still
in counseling over by god they came out
of school in four years debt-free all
right and they know how to work yep all
three of them your kids are amazing
it's such a great it's a great testimony
and i also look at parents who have
great college funds saved up for their
kids you know but they still are saving
for retirement and they're on a budget
and i encourage you to still push your
kids to go for scholarships still push
them to be strategic with their
education just because the money is
there doesn't mean that they're not
capable of contributing and trying to be
strategic with their own journey if they
can get a full ride awesome go for it
mine had a full ride off a dad and they
still had to work yep that's part of a
part of life it's good for us you know
how to work daniel worked in a mattress
store selling mattresses
and he was good at it too that's what's
scary he's still the ramsey family
mattress expert anytime we need
knowledge on that we just go to daniel
yeah i didn't know that
interesting information about daniel
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christina ellis number one
best-selling author and ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
take your questions about your life and
your money the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
san francisco riley is on the line it
says on my screen you are debt-free
congratulations
thank you thank you very cool how much
did you pay off
i paid off a little under a hundred
thousand ninety-eight thousand five
hundred and sixty-two dollars i will
round that to a hundred way to go how
long did that take
uh 44 months good for you and your range
of income during that time
i started out
i started out at 60 and i'm out about
100 now good for you what do you do for
a
living
i'm an international tax consultant at a
big four accounting firm wow
nice land good job so what kind of debt
was the 100k
all student loans
oh man and you cleared it all in less
than four years
yep look at you so how old are you
uh 25.
so you started immediately after college
and dug into this
yep i graduated from school in three
years trying to save a little bit of
cost there and then as soon as i got out
i just started attacking the debt
okay tell us your story how did you know
how to do that and how did you connect
up with ramsey stuff
yeah um well when i was trying to you
know pick a university my parents you
know talk to me they said they gave me a
set budget for how much i had for school
um so i knew when i was picking
university how much i had and i kind of
walked through with my dad you know
different um
different uh schools that i could go to
and the amount of debt that i would have
if i went here if i went there so i kind
of made an educated decision based on
you know scholarships that i got and if
i could graduate early or not so i was
sort of already prepared to you know pay
off my debt as quickly as possible
before i'd um you know started listening
to your show
but then about senior year of college i
started listening and i would listen
every day and i was getting really
really excited once i would start
working so that i could start paying off
the debt and
i'm a nerd so i had all my excel budgets
and everything planned out every payment
for every month um and how i was going
to do it so i would just listen to your
show every day and i would um you know
track my budget using every dollar and
uh every month i just paid off a little
bit a little bit and then next thing i
knew it was gone
that is awesome and i love that you got
started so young that you were motivated
to just push right in and get after it
you're 25 years old and all of your debt
is gone that's incredible so what kind
of things did you do to get out of debt
obviously you said you budgeted but did
you take on any side hustles were you
super scrappy did you save money in
different spots what did that look like
for you
yeah i think the biggest thing is just
being really intentional with your money
like i was definitely scrappy i did the
beans and rice you know obviously i
wasn't i wasn't eating out a bunch i was
you know cooking regularly you know
being as as frugal as i could be but
still you know living the life of a
young professional living in a city and
and trying to find some balance there
but i really just think the most
important part was being intentional and
being consistent and you know if there's
a month when you slipped up or went on a
trip with friends next month walk back
down update your budget figure out what
you have left and i think for me it was
just a matter of being consistent and
paying attention to what was happening
made all the difference
that's awesome a lot of people in the
early 20s are not focused on this did
your friends know that you were doing
this
yes every every person i have met
knows that i was paying off my debt very
aggressively i was extremely vocal about
it a lot of my friends have asked me to
help set up budgets for them or help
look at their budgets but most people
are like oh you know i also have student
loans but you know we'll put them off
there i have so much you know it'll
it'll take forever and pay off always
you know have my student loans but i
just encourage them like you know what
you can pay this off and i wanted i
didn't i didn't want this hundred
thousand dollars living over my head you
know as a 21 year old looking up and
being like oh my gosh a hundred thousand
dollars how am i ever going to pay that
off it seems so not feasible um
so i think just being consistent i think
also for me the most frustrating part as
an accountant is that i paid twenty
thousand dollars of interest alone
twenty thousand dollars about a hundred
thousand was just interest
and um that just to me was the most
ridiculous thing in the world so i was
not gonna pay a dime more of interest
than i had to
you are so fun
you're gonna do you're gonna be so rich
i mean who gets excited about getting
out of debt uh people that listen to the
show and accountants that's it
so you got a double dose you're great
you're absolutely amazing very very well
done riley very well
i love that you're just like i'm not i'm
not going to keep it quiet i'm going to
tell all my friends even if they think
i'm weird or crazy i'm going to actually
change their perspective and motivate
them to do it
that kind of enthusiasm it's a
contagious she talked some people into
it she converted some people i'm just
saying it happened it definitely
happened i mean you average i mean keto
you average like over 2 000 a month for
44 months that's like 2 300 bucks a
month for
44 months that's pretty rowdy that's a
lot of money that's a big old house
payment actually in most places not in
san fran but in most places
good for you well done hey we got a copy
of baby steps millionaires for you
because you're gonna be one uh you are
right on track the number two most
likely
uh career field to become
a millionaire is accountant and so
number two number one's engineer number
three's teacher just to let you guys
know and that's from all the data and
the actual hardcore research we've done
and it's all in the baby steps
millionaire's book for you by the way
it's also got a copy of total money
makeover to give to one of those friends
you're trying to push along you can
inspire them and a one-year membership
to financial peace university the brand
new videos are out and uh you can
that'll help someone get started you can
go through it if you haven't been and
someone else can or you can get one of
your buddies through it or however you
want to do it it's all there for you we
want to give gift you some things to say
we are impressed we're proud of you
you're pretty impressive young lady well
done
thank you thank you riley in san
francisco 100 000 paid off in 44 months
making 60 to 100 count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two one i'm set
she
free
fun
oh that that one's going somewhere yeah
just watch her dust right there eat her
dog it's pretty incredible beautiful
stuff i love that she said that the the
you know this journey it only took her
three years the thing that drove her
crazy was that twenty thousand dollars
in interest like this is great and she
got after it get it girl perfect
motivation i love it i love it hey
people are out there right now with
inflation
recession
interest rates going up
stock market going down
real estate's in freak out mode
people are freaking out and one of the
things that causes you to freak out is a
lack of knowledge
if you know what's going on
even
if there's
pain
you can at least face it with
intelligence and intentionality uh you
got to know what's going on and the
second thing you have to have is
perspective
and uh perspective means history it
means looking at you know how long do
you you know how long do we need to look
at this what kind of lens do we look at
this through because the smaller your
lens when you're looking at a hard time
the more drama you bring into your life
because you start you start
extrapolating and saying this is going
crazy it's out of control and so that's
happening with real estate right now
people are panicking
rumors of the market crashing the real
estate market bubble ending
endless questions about it all kinds of
theories by people who
really shouldn't have a theory but
they've got one anyway
about what's going to happen with the
markets we're going to take care of all
this
we have a free
underline that word free
live stream this thursday night rachel
cruz george campbell and i are going to
be going through the actual data
having to do with the housing market and
we're going to show you that it's not
going to crash
i'm going to tell you what's really
going on
and we're going to address lots of
questions and comments and even trolling
that we've had
from the old social media people out
there
so we kind of you know we know what
you're thinking in other words and we're
going to talk to you about it and show
you what's going on exactly in detail
graphs and charts a little quick college
class about an hour long
7 p.m
central
this thursday
the real estate reality check
it is free you need to go sign up ahead
of time at ramseysolutions.com
ramseysolutions.com realitycheck get
signed up we'll see you thursday night
at 7 central
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today zach's in harrisburg
pennsylvania hey zach welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave it's me and my wife michaela
here it's great to talk to you thanks
for taking our call sure
what's up um so quick quick background
uh my wife and i we just paid off 289
000 worth of debt whoo well we made them
hey yeah thank you we're very excited it
took us uh 21 months to do it
so that's the background that's where we
are our question is now our
financial goal right now is we want to
buy a house we're still renting
and our long term financial goal in 10
to 15 years is we'd also like to get
some sort of small vacation house
the question is
what's the most efficient way to get to
that point would you recommend buying
our primary house you know that we live
in
paying that off as quick as possible
getting all of our extra income towards
that or would you also recommend
um
putting some money into some sort of
index fund while we simultaneously pay
off our house early what's the most
efficient way to get to that goal
i would simply pay off your house and
then
pile up cash and buy your buy your toy a
vacation home is a toy
and it's a wonderful toy i've got a nice
lake house that i enjoy most every
weekend in the summer
and uh but it's a toy
it's a it's a luxury item
and so we always pay cash for everything
around ramsey but we certainly pay cash
for toys
and so
and you do that kind of thing i when i
bought that lake house i actually bought
a house that i tore down and built
another house up there later
but uh i i um it was a big deal for
sharon and i like like i can hear we got
our house paid off we were starting to
make a little money and i thrown some
money into an index fund and i found
this little house on the water i didn't
even have a dock i had to build the dock
and uh and you know it really wasn't
that great a house but it was a great
lot
and uh you know we still own it 22 years
later and uh built a nice home on it on
the property now we tore that little
house down there actually we donated it
and um but yeah all the while i paid
cash because i got to tell you man
uh the more stuff you own the more
repairman you have to know
and so it's not all glory to own all
these extra toys
they break
and you have to you know pay the heat
and air guy to go down there and fix the
ductwork whatever it is you know there's
always something going on right so you
want to be doing all of that with cash
and with no loans and and where it's
margin and extra money and all that kind
of stuff it sounds like you're making a
lot of money so it sounds like you're
going to be able to buy your home and
get it paid off very quickly and then
start saving and get you a beach you
know condo or whatever and then maybe
maybe you move up later into even nicer
property and pay cash for that that'd be
fine and we've actually done that with
some of our toys we started at a
reasonable level and then later move up
but we we allocate a small percentage of
our income
uh to increased lifestyle
and uh
and that's worked out really really well
over the years i've got a incredible
lifestyle uh
nowhere near it's it's an it's a very
small percentage of my overall net worth
or my income but and then that makes it
tolerable if the stupid thing breaks
no not if when the stupid thing breaks
and uh christina and all the ramsey
personalities were just down at the lake
house it was a lot of fun but stuff
broke down there while we were there you
know i mean it's like god there's dead
gum hot water heaters out you know
remember that it's like you know so
that's just part of it right yeah it's
part of the journey but i love the
long-term thinking and i love the fact
that you're already dreaming like that
you guys are obviously motivated paying
off nearly 300 000 in debt thus far and
dreaming long term but use that dream to
really get to hustling now and pay off
that first house so that later you can
live and give like no one else
like it's you know keep that motivation
that's a great thing but you know follow
the path follow the baby steps go
through step by step so that later you
can fully enjoy it and it's not going to
be a stress when something breaks down
because your house is paid off and then
soon you'll get your next house paid off
and you'll have that huge fund of money
if anything breaks down and it's not a
stress yeah the way i started doing that
was 100 years ago before i actually went
broke
i was still a math nerd and um i i
bought a boat
a ski boat on payments
and then i'm such a nerd
that i added up how many times we go
skiing and about how many times i would
ski and i figured out what it cost me
per minute to ski
in the actual time i was behind the
thing and it made me about throw up
because you know when you because the
number the number of minutes you spend
behind a boat in a summer no i mean if
you're there all the time it's still not
that number of minutes versus the cost
of the stupid thing and the payments and
the insurance and all and it just takes
all the fun out of it so never do that
never add it up
number one uh but number two never never
have payments on that kind of stuff and
that way you don't have to think about
adding it all up it needs to be
throwaway money because it's a toy
that's what it comes down to jordan's
with us jordan is in pittsburgh hi
jordan how are you
good how are you guys doing better than
i deserve what's up
awesome hey i bought a landscaping
author business earlier this year yeah
you're coming in you're coming in and
out of your phone speak directly into it
please
can you hear me now yes sir
okay i bought a lawn care and
landscaping business earlier this year
and i need to buy a new truck a bigger
truck so that i can hold my trailers
and i'm just wondering
what i should be spending on that and if
i should be using your guidelines
or like a personal vehicle no i wouldn't
use those guidelines you spend only cash
no borrowed money
and
and it's business overhead so here's the
way the formula works and you already
know this but i'm gonna say it out loud
okay
the more money you spend on the truck
the less profit you have
so if a 20 000 truck will do the job and
you go spend 30 because i want a truck
well that's not good business that's
just being a redneck
yeah you know what i'm saying
so you buy a tr you buy the least thing
that will get the job done
and um
you know i don't know what that is in
your case and getting the job done also
means it doesn't break down all the time
doesn't give me a hassle because i
bought so cheap as a piece of crap right
right yeah so you know but this idea
that somehow to pull lawnmowers you know
need to go spend 100 grand well that's
complete garbage of course you don't
right
and you don't want to give up all your
profits to the dead gum car dealer
yeah
so
what is there a difference between in
the long term if you'd spend 20 000 on a
truck and it lasts you maybe four years
versus spending 40 000
but it would last you twice as long and
you probably have less repairs during
that time
uh
not true
the difference in a forty thousand
dollar truck and a twenty thousand
dollar truck is not
that it gets that much more life i mean
you take care of a twenty thousand truck
it's gonna run a long time
and uh
and uh you know
no the idea that if you spend more
you're going to get you're not going to
get twice the life out of a 40 000 you
get out of a 20 000 not true and you're
not going to have twice the repairs on
the 20 that you have on a 40 not true
that's not that's not accurate on just
on vehicle maintenance and managing a
vehicle here's the other thing if you
look around
uh who is in business five years from
now in your industry it's not the guy
with the shiny new brand new truck
he's out of business later because he's
got payments
and because he put all his dadgum money
in a truck instead of in his pocket
so again i you know when we're buying
computers around here or we're buying
studio equipment around here we buy good
equipment that will do the job
but we don't buy
a microphone for prestige
we don't buy a computer for prestige we
don't buy
a screen or a building for prestige we
get a lot of use out of everything we
spend around here because it's a
business transaction you're making an
investment and you need to make a return
on
investment and that's what you're
looking for so don't don't fall into the
old
uh you know i don't buy somebody else's
problems because when you buy a new
truck and you drive it a month you know
what it is a used truck
hello
so yeah i i would buy in your case i buy
a 15 to 20 000 truck if that'll do it i
definitely would not buy a 40 000 truck
in a lawn care business i just wouldn't
do it i think you can get the job done a
lot cheaper than that and i work with
landscape people all the time through
entre leadership i talk to them all the
time 300 000 a year 100 000 a year 500
000 a year top line gross we talk to
them all the time equipment is a
constant problem in your business
be careful it'll eat your lunch this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help folks build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships christina alice ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today as we answer
your questions at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five john is
in atlanta starting off this hour hey
john welcome to the ramsay show
hey christina dave thank you for taking
my call i really appreciate it sure
what's up
hey uh i got a question i'm 48 years old
me and my wife have saved enough for our
retirement at least i think is enough we
have no debt uh all that all we've got
is a house payment i got two kids in
college uh two boys that i'm we are
paying for the education paying cash
um here's what my dilemma is i'm hoping
to retire by 55 that's about seven years
and i think i have reached a point when
i've been when i do my calculations with
my retirement savings so far that i have
my contributions now don't make a whole
lot of difference
just the way the compound interest works
uh 10 years now from now or six years
seven years from now
i was wondering if i can just stop
contributing just do minimum four
percent so that i could get an
employer's match
and then start
saving after tax
uh pay my house off pay for my two kids
college my younger son who will be
starting medical school in about a year
and a half pay for his medical school
cash that he doesn't have to take any
loans and then me and my wife can retire
at 55
uh and then everything you know just
lead the way my investments are and now
i if
you know 10 or 8 a year and a compound
interest in seven years i should have a
decent amount to retire how much is in
there now
at the beginning of this year it was 2.6
million in there
okay
well if you don't touch it and it's
invested at uh 10 it'll double in seven
years
right that's what i'm so i'm hoping even
if it doesn't double this four million
at least four to four and a half yeah
it'll double i mean if you've got it in
good mutual funds you're going to make
that on it so
um yeah i mean you're gonna have five
million dollars at 55 years old and
you're saying you want to you want to
and i've got two investment properties
that are completely paid for what's your
what do you own your house
uh i owe 130k on a house as value is 900
000. yeah what do you make
we make close to about 200 000 a year
yeah you've just been very wise over a
long period of time then well done
good job i appreciate it good job yeah
yeah i like your plan yeah cash flow the
kids college pay off the house as soon
as possible
um
and uh
you know here's the thing i want you to
run the numbers out two ways
because the amount you're putting in
your 401k is only
what 19 grand
okay that's right but i'm also doing for
um
roth and you know yep okay so 30 grand
out of 200 let's call it that all right
whoopee
and so that doesn't really you know if
you ran it out saying i'm going to keep
fully funding everything how long does
it take me to pay off the house and cash
flow the kids college
you can do that by the way
or i do the plan or or run the numbers
out with your plan at four percent how
long does it take you to pay off the
house and cash flow the kids college
because after both of those things are
done you need to crank this back up
anyway just to keep the stinking
government's hands off the money
right yeah i i i don't i don't think you
if you run the numbers out the cash it's
just a straight cash flow analysis it's
really i mean it's just it's it's sixth
grade math you can do it
everybody can do it and and you're
certainly smart enough to do it um
but i i think you're going to find that
20 you know don't do the roths at least
do the 401k that 20 000 a year is not
going to delay this whole program
over this seven year period of time
but about a year
yeah actually if you think about it
david's about 50 grand because my wife
does the same thing right so
okay well
yeah i wouldn't have you both
no i wouldn't have you doing that anyway
i would only have you doing 15 of your
income going into retirement
that's baby step four and that would be
30 grand
on 200 right okay yeah yeah that's our
baby step four and if you do 30 grand
versus only doing
uh seven grand you know we got a 23 000
swing
and per year and how much does that
delay you paying off 130 000 house not
much it's not even a year difference
you're giving this uh you're giving the
stopping of this
uh retirement or virtual stopping in
this retirement way too much weight in
your head it's not as heavy as you think
it is
yeah i think what's what's bothering me
i'm not bothering me what what i do want
to make sure that my kids are are
debt-free with their graduation oh i
completely agree with that run that out
and if you got to borrow money you got
to borrow money it's all bets are off
stop you do what you're playing okay but
i don't think you've got to borrow money
make 200 grand
so i think you you know i think you're
putting too much into retirement you
need to get down to 15
and then you need to start throwing
money at kids college and at your house
work the baby steps straight up and i
think you're gonna get there
i don't think you're gonna see much
difference
in that or stopping the 15 making it
only four percent yeah but john you're
very impressive you're killing it to
have 2.6 million in retirement at 48
you're you're doing amazing and i love
that you're calculating things so well
that's how he got there right he paid
attention it's very obvious that yeah
you you do the math you work the plan
and you're very diligent
yeah that
just i think that
guys that are listening you're going
well that's impressive yeah you know
what you know what he did
he just did it on purpose winning is not
an accidental event
no one accidentally has an awesome
marriage
no one accidentally has great kids i
don't know how they turned out they just
let them run loose and they worked out
it doesn't work that way you know no one
accidentally has a career that is
amazing
and
fulfilling it's it's a matter yeah it's
intentionality no one accidentally
becomes wealthy they don't and if they
do they don't stay wealthy often they
usually lose it
and so you know this random accident
winning is a series of intentional acts
and john is a walking poster child for
that he's an inspiring dude yeah and the
cool thing is it's intentional acts that
may feel annoying to do right now it may
feel like it takes effort it is annoying
it is
it is but the long-term reward is
amazing and the pain of not doing it
long-term of not having enough in your
account for retirement for having to
take out some money for student loans
all this other stuff is way more painful
than being intentional on the front end
and you know dealing with
doing a budget running the numbers and
being really really intentional with
your money up front yeah
there are some people whose mom and dad
are both skinny so they're skinny
but most the rest of us it's not a
natural act
most the rest of us are donut eaters you
know i mean oh my god you know i had a
friend whose dad was a beanpole and so
he was a beanpole and he could eat
anything it's just made me mad at him
all the time but but most of the time
you know even you can even screw up good
dna sometimes you know
and so it's an intentional
act and that guy right there you know he
wasn't freaking out he wasn't wringing
his hands he wasn't money obsessed he
wasn't greedy he wasn't a horrible
capitalist that had taken advantage of
children in the salt mines he was just
an intentional guy
and he's got 2.6 million dollars
baby steps millionaires this is how it
happens boys and girls i love it i love
it i love it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
christina alice ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
moms and dads if you've got school age
kids the last thing you want is for them
to be normal
i mean normal doesn't work out well you
want them to be weird like you and uh in
a good way weird i'm not trying to make
your children strange i'm just saying
normal out there isn't working you don't
want to be average you don't want to be
mediocre uh that's why you've already
got them listening to ramsey show in the
backseat of the car you're raising the
next generation of smart kids we're on
board with that and we got tons of stuff
to help you and even your kids
teachers packed into our back to school
sale one of the biggest challenges
teachers face is getting students to
engage in healthy classroom
conversations that's why mental health
expert dr john deloney created classroom
editions of his questions for humans
conversation starters they're made for
elementary middle and high school
students to help them build lifelong
friendships through real in-person
not texting
conversations
that's like in person like human beings
have done for centuries long before
apple invented a magic wand
and at home keep the fun and learning
going with our popular kids books the
adventure pack a family favorite that
includes the story time collection
financial peace junior the smart saver
bank all kinds of things and if there's
a teacher in your life or in your kid's
life pick up for them one of the
questions for humans classroom additions
as a gift
grab one of our family favorite
children's products help keep teaching
your kids the right way about money and
shop the back to school sale at
ramseysolutions.com
matt is with us in rochester new york hi
matt welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave and christine thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
so my wife and i
we are i'm 31 she's 30 we're in baby
step 3b
thanks to your guys teachings that we
have been following for almost three
years now so good job
thank you thank you um
so we're getting to that point where
we're looking to become homeowners but
it's a little bit more complicated now
that
home prices are quite a bit higher than
they were
you know year over year
and interest rates are going up too
so
one of the things that i wanted to
confirm is
when you guys say to budget 25 of
take-home pay
for a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage that
does not include retirement and college
funding right but it does include
property taxes insurance hoa fees etc
yeah i would just be your house payment
so the point is this
you can qualify for almost double that
payment
and when people do that you know what
happens
they got no money they become house poor
that's why they call them mortgage
brokers exactly you got the plan and
they become house poor because you're
broker and broker and so but you then
then the next time a car comes up it
becomes a car payment because you got no
margin to save up for the next car next
time the heat and air goes out you got
no margin if it's over the emergency
fund you're screwed because you you
can't cover it and so
because it's all going to a stinking
house payment because you saddled
yourself with that so you're obviously
not going to go that far over into the
land of stupidity our guideline at 20
our guideline of 25 of your take-home
pay
meaning uh whatever you're coming home
with not counting uh just a taxes taxes
out of your check is all
what would you get home after tax
now if you got uh okay if you got health
care coming out even health insurance i
don't you can take that out of the
equation if you want i don't care the
point of the whole formula is not the
nuanced exact percentage the point of
the formula is keep a small enough house
payment that there's margin in your life
and do it on a 15 year so you can get
the house paid off because that's what
millionaires do
absolutely so this past weekend we
actually got pre-approved for a mortgage
payment that was
29
of our take-home paid now this was five
percent 30-year conventional fixed rate
and
the problem was as well as with the
closing costs and the down payment that
was going to have to dig into our baby
step 3 fund so i know obviously that is
not something you guys would recommend
basically what i was working on was
so i built my own mortgage calculator
where
the property taxes so we live in new
york so we have pretty high property
taxes so on a 200k property you're
looking at about 6 300 a month or sorry
6300 a year
in property taxes
so five hundred and fifty dollars a
month hazard insurance of about seventy
five dollars
uh prepaids
so and then for the closing costs weekly
paids prepaids are not monthly they
apply that sets up your escrow account
to pay your taxes and insurance
right right so
for our closing costs yeah so for for
our prepaids we were quoted 81.05
and our closing costs of 62.73 so just
out of curiosity i created a calculator
where if say we were going to go look at
a 175 000 house it would calculate those
down to three quarters of that two
hundred thousand dollar quote just for
rough math
so i looked into
okay like if we took out a fifteen year
fixed rate at
four point nine two percent which is
what the average 15-year fixed rate is
running at
so with our take-home pay we could
afford just for the mortgage not
counting the property taxes and
insurance about
957 dollars a month but even out of 175
000 property
that calculates out to about
53 000 dollars 400 down
plus the prepayment i'm going to stop so
i'm what's your
question well so i guess the question is
is if we're going to be renting for a
while longer
would it make sense to potentially start
doing
baby step four so i have a roth 401k you
can do whatever you want baby step 3b
is zero going into retirement up to 15
percent going into retirement and baby
step forward and obviously the more you
put into retirement the less you're
going to put into your down payment fund
yeah yeah and so and the more you know
and what you're trying to do is get into
a house
at this stage
of the game and so here what do you guys
do for a living
so i'm a business analyst and my wife is
a teacher age so what did you make two
years ago
three years ago what were you making
before covid
uh before well actually i've had pretty
good pay raises what i'm asking two
yeah so two years ago
i was at
sixty thousand and my wife what do you
make now she's
75 i do okay and so if you take out a 29
today in two years it's going to be 25
right okay and if that's pr
principal interest taxes and insurance
on a 15 year you know that's not the end
of the world my point is not to take out
you know 38 which you can qualify for
right right and you don't want to do
that and but don't over nerd this okay
it's a concept
the concept is big stinking house
payment means no money
so the concept is get reasonable house
payments so there's margin and i can get
through getting this thing paid off but
if you've got an income that's on an
upward trajectory like yours is you're
going to be at the 25 within 18 to 24
months and you're not going to have
wholesale violated this concept and made
yourself house poor that's what we're
trying to avoid
not trying to figure out some hard and
fast parasitical rule the the the reason
we teach you this is to limit your keep
you from going out test driving
bentley's and then having to buy a
chevrolet it's just hard to do that
yeah that was my thought is it's not to
be legalistic it's not to try to follow
technicalities it's to give you freedom
in the long run and to build wealth we
don't want you tied into something
that's going to really stress you out
long term and prevent you from really
building wealth yeah but i mean you know
hey i couldn't do it it was a 25.5
percent
of my take-home pay oh shut up that's
not what we're talking about okay and
that's not this guy but i mean if you
get to the point understand the reason
for these things and then like make
grown-up decisions based on that guys
that's what we want you to do this is
the ramsey shop
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
so
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
here on the ramsey show jared and
kristen are with us in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
hey guys how are you doing well welcome
welcome where do you guys live
we live here in nashville oh cool good
well congratulations on being debt-free
how much did you pay off we paid off 227
thousand dollars in exactly six years
with the last 189 000 paid off in 22
months while cash flowing a master's
degree whoa
jamming what was your range of income
during that six years we started at 60
000 and ended up at 200. cool what do
y'all do for a living
we own a hardwood flooring company and i
also teach history in high school ah
very good very good so what kind of debt
was this 227 000 it was our house ah
look at the weird people
way to go weirdos very weird paid off
house how old are you weirdos
i am 37
and i'm 40. all right paid off house by
the time you're 40. and so what's this
house worth when we bought it like i
said it was 227 now it is over 500. yeah
oh very good very good and you own it
yes it's all yours feels different
doesn't it it does it's a weird
sensation yes no payments anywhere in
the world none no
wow
wow how much in retirement do you have
saved
right now we're trying to play catch up
we only have 150. okay all right so by
the time you're 43 or 44 you're gonna be
millionaires yeah
yeah well done y'all
baby steps millionaires looking at them
in the future here well done y'all cool
cool cool so what in the world inspired
this journey y'all went crazy here you
did all kinds of stuff
uh
well actually it started a long time ago
uh when my oldest was two years old um
we were really struggling financially at
that point we were making 28 000
and
we were in a place of desperation and i
was at a friend's house she gave me your
book i read it in one day
i'm the type a personality and i said
hey we're doing this i hope you're
coming along
he is very easygoic balances me out and
he said yeah this makes sense so we paid
off consumer debt a little less than 20
000 back in 2012.
and when we bought our house i had the
vision of paying it off my goal was to
pay it off by my 40th birthday
and then with our business
it just felt disorganized as far as the
finances so i
sent him a link to an entree leadership
podcast episode and i said hey you're
going to listen to this today please and
he
came back on board yeah i actually read
the book and the biggest thing that
stood out for me in the book was when
you said whatever's wrong with your
business it's your fault
um so they got me to look at my business
look at where we were going what we were
doing
and surely it was my fault so we started
to change things started investing our
business more invested in our employees
and ever since then it started to grow
very cool good for you well done
that's a big deal i mean and when you
start a business it's
you know you're just all you can
you know especially in the early days
it's you're the ceo the chief everything
officer you've got to do everything so
you ain't even got time to stop and
think you just got to work and uh it's a
very difficult stage and you really rose
above that well done yeah and once he
saw that vision of me saying hey if we
get organized this is what we can do and
then when he got on board it was
game on from there that's awesome you
guys had that huge income jump 60 000 to
200 was that the business getting
organized and the majority of that was
the business getting organized and
growing yes that's awesome then what
else did you all do to get out of debt
honestly it was just persistence being
intentional every single day and we
still went on vacations because we were
in baby steps four five and six you sure
but
we just put thought into everything we
do do we really want this or do we want
this more
and one thing that we did to stay
motivated was
really encourage each other we would
send each other screenshots of our
mortgage account every time we made a
payment on it
so we would surprise each other like ooh
put you know this amount on there and so
we were each other's cheerleaders to
keep us going and we got our kids
involved i had a little thing on the
on the refrigerator that they could
color in
um the houses as we paid off you know so
much
they got to color it and so yeah i think
we balanced it out too we had fun but we
always looked at well how much money we
put toward the principal on the mortgage
this month before we decided to do
something
um if it was at our average where we
expected to be where our goal was like
six thousand dollars after the principal
then okay then we can go do something
fun but if it was below that we held off
and made sure we put at least six
thousand dollars toward the principal
that month yeah that's awesome so
someone who feels like y'all back in
2012 they're making 28 000 they're
they're feeling overwhelmed with their
finances they're listening right now
thinking wow i can't even imagine
paying off a house what would you tell
them
i would say
the plan works whether you are making 28
000 or 208 thousand we have done it at
both ends of the spectrum
um it takes a lot of grit
to
just keep moving through those obstacles
my i lost both of my parents within
eight months of each other
he got into a car wreck um
you know all of these things kept
happening and it kept feeling like
you know what else is gonna come at us
um and it was
working together and you know either way
we can either get out of debt and all of
these horrible things are still going to
happen or we can be more financially
secure and when they come at us
you know i can have that hope
of seeing a brighter day yeah wow wow
it's powerful that's fine that's well
done because you know the truth is what
you've done for the last six years while
doing all the other things you did
during those six years
is a complete pain in the butt yeah it's
hard
you know we're here to celebrate today
but grit is is an understatement i mean
you got to have grit and you got to have
you got to be a little mad and you got
to be pushy and you know and and then
you look up and you're 37 and 40 years
old and paid for a house
yeah but but you know it it you know we
we do these debt-free screams every hour
just about on the show here one an hour
and i always want to i don't often
enough talk about how hard it is
it is hard it's an adventure to go
through what you've been through and
anytime you go on an adventure and you
do it together you come out more unified
uh because you fought a battle together
and and now you're now you're uh you
know you're you're two members of the
same army at this point uh the same
platoon at this point and it changes
everything because it's hard yeah i mean
it's hard
the only problem is it's worth it yes
100
good for you guys i'm so proud of y'all
thank you you're amazing young couple
beautifully done and
you know revolutionize your business
your life uh got a master's what's your
master's in my master's is in uh
education from lipscomb yeah good for
you y'all are such shining examples i
love that like it wasn't just a straight
line you guys can stand there and say
there were ups there were major downs
but you did it and now you're standing
here getting ready to do your debt-free
screen how does it feel not a payment in
the world
it's great it was weird the first month
not to have a mortgage payment to
actually pay ourselves instead of paying
the bank yeah yeah and it's just kind of
like i just set down a 300 pound weight
yeah
and just and mentally it's a
it's such a relief because you know
right now business is booming
construction's booming in nashville but
knowing that the houses paid off knowing
that things slow down that it doesn't
take as much to live off of so even
things do slow down we're still okay and
you don't have to take bad customers
just to have a customer exactly yeah and
which one the weird thing is you'll end
up making more money yeah that's the
weird thing and that's happening because
there's a relaxation in the process now
well done guys well done all right bring
the kiddos up what are their names and
ages
we have jackson who's 12. sam is nine
and christopher is six all right ready
to go we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you as we predicted
you'll be there in just a few years
that's the direction you're going how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can too we got a copy of
total money makeover and a one-year
subscription to financial peace
university all right 227 000 paid off in
six years house and everything they're
weird jared and kristen count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream all right
one two three
three
way to go you guys
man that is awesome
this
is the ramsey shaft
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
christina harris ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five dana is with us in new
york city hi dana how are you
hi dave and christina thank you for
taking my phone call and thank you for
changing my family tree sure what's up
i have two questions for you today if
that's okay
sure okay um my husband and i are
receiving an inheritance check in the
amount of three hundred thousand dollars
and we disagree on how to best spend it
for our future
um a little bit about us we're 32 we're
on baby step six with no children yet we
have um 286 thousand dollars left to pay
on our home and our home is valued at
459.
um my husband would like to invest the
money in the market in a large cap fund
but i would like to pay off the mortgage
with that money what would be your
recommendation
well apparently you're on baby step six
but he's not
right yes yeah
so um
because i mean
it's a trick question you already knew
the answer
he insisted i call so i'm calling to
confirm yeah so the concern is not that
the money came from an inheritance the
concern is that you guys are not in
agreement on what to do with money which
means you're not aligned on whether
you're working our system or anybody's
system
okay because if you're working our
system the answer is already it's a
foregone conclusion you're gonna pay the
house off
yes yeah because there's never been a
time in the baby step history of doing
this for 30 years that i told somebody
to oh no let's put money in mutual funds
instead of paying off the house
never one time have i ever said that
anywhere anytime in the history of my
life
correct yes you knew what i was going to
say
so you i mean you tricked your husband
if you if if i became the
if i became the arbitrator of this then
you tricked your husband because you
knew what the answer was
well he wanted to put it into the market
because he was running a 30-year uh
projection on it and he thought that it
might be a better long-term investment
than paying off the mortgage but
we're following the baby steps so
okay
well then do we need to discuss for a
minute why the baby steps work better
than his plan
i think it would be great for him to
hear okay all right because i'm a nerd
like him so it took me a while to get
there number one i started with the idea
that i don't borrow money because the
bible says the borrower's slave to the
lender i started from a faith
perspective
later on i'm a math nerd and i i had to
dig into the math i had to figure it out
not because i wanted to play god but
because i really knew that god was
smarter than me and i was just trying to
figure out what he was saying so here's
the thing when your husband says i'm
going to put money in a large cap fund
he's looking at a 10 to 12 rate of
return on a good large cap
okay
and he's thinking okay instead of paying
off my three or four percent mortgage i
can make 10 12
so i'm making a spread here on that
money
and and he and then he ran a spreadsheet
out based on that which is what i would
have done because i'm a classic nerd
like he is
you know if that worked
then why would we ever pay off the house
well what you left out of that formula
and what i left out of that formula in
my early days what he's leaving out of
the formula now too
is risk
and 100
of the foreclosures occur on a home with
a mortgage
when you're walking around without a
mortgage your risk has gone down and to
mathematically not include risk
in your math formula means your math
formula is incomplete
and no one does that in this discussion
until
i kind of came up with it so
uh you know if if you're doing a
sophisticated analysis on a company and
you're buying stock in that company one
of the things you would do is is you
would become concerned if the company
had too much debt
because that stock then is riskier debt
equals risk and you would discount the
price of the stock if you're doing a
sophisticated analysis based on the
the the level of bonds they're carrying
and the other debt instruments that
they're carrying so the more in debt the
company is the more likely it is to fail
everyone will say yes we all agree to
that and so debt equals risk and debt
equals risk here now is it manageable
risk yeah but so so it's a small
backache
it's manageable but your back still
hurts
and so you know that that that's what
we're dealing with here so
the end of the story is that when you
don't have any debt you end up making
better decisions relationally
medically your physical health is better
you're more likely to have a higher
quality and lasting marriage your
children are more functional because
there's not any weight on your shoulders
tense between your shoulder blades when
you get home at night
everything changes and when you quantify
all that math up it'll kick that little
mutual fund's butt
because you lowered the risk and you set
down the 300 pound weight that you got
used to carrying and all of society
carries it and so they think you're
strange for even having this discussion
yeah it's quote unquote normal
but dana we're really sorry for your
loss too it's not a fun way to get your
house paid off through an inheritance
because obviously that means you must
have lost someone but i do hope that in
paying off a house it'll be a good way
to honor them being able to be debt-free
and free of any payments that'll be a
really wonderful way to bring honor to
that money yeah
and i i do want you guys to go back and
address the idea that somehow dana you
got on the baby steps and he didn't
because that's going to be important
going forward that you are
aligned on money and what we're going to
do with it so i'll give you an example
dana now that we got our house paid off
many many many many years ago sharon and
i did and so you know how do we have to
become aligned about money well one of
the things we did was
um we laid out a
uh a percentage
calculation
to every dollar of money that we now get
because i'll get a big check from a
publisher or a big check from this or a
big check from that and if i don't
already have that aligned with my wife
where that's going then i have to redo
that every time and that burns a lot of
calories
in the relationship yeah and so we have
a simple system a certain percentage of
every check we get now
goes we were christians
evangelical christians so we tithe 10
i'm going to tell you what part of it is
we set aside 40 because the government
takes that because we make a lot of
money we're evil we're rich we must be
punished
and so 40 goes to them 10 to the church
so now i got 50 left over that 50 i'm
not going to tell you what it is but
it's broken between three categories
increased lifestyle which is a very
small percentage of that
increased investing and increased
generosity beyond the tithe and so every
time i get a check in i can apply that
formula to it because sharon and i are
aligned on our system
and i don't even think about it
shouldn't i think about it and so we got
some money in the fun account over here
and i say hey let's get you a different
car that'll be fun and she goes she
doesn't have to go oh where'd that come
from are we investing enough or are we
generous enough
it's all set it's all done we'll have to
have the discussion again because we are
in alignment and dana that's what i want
for you more than i want your house paid
off even
because that going forward you guys
being in agreement on principle of what
you're going to do how you're going to
do things
is
that and so and you know other
principles we use we do not give to or
invest in anything unless we're both in
agreement and have peace about it that's
good
when in doubt don't
i've got a funny feeling about him
then don't donate to his ministry or
don't invest in his thing
or her thing you know because every time
she has a feeling it costs me a lot of
money if i go against it because she her
feelings are always right drive me nuts
but um but you know that's the thing so
that that's what i want for you dana i
want that kind of alignment to where
we don't have to
and you know
you know if we get money in from
wherever it comes inheritance bonus
check sale of something
what are we gonna do with it this is
what we're gonna do yeah and i love that
you all have a system too that makes it
so
simple it takes a lot of the stress off
of everyday decisions you don't have to
revisit it every time right
right
automatic and so and then it gets it
releases you because sharon's a freaking
tight wad i mean she it's hard for her
to enjoy money not hard for me i'm a
spender like rachel but um but but but
you know if it once she knows it went in
that
lifestyle bucket
then she'll go buy you know another
stupid thing for the house or something
that she wants and not feel guilty about
it right that's great yeah because it
comes out of the stupid house bucket you
know that kind of thing right yeah but
you gotta have buckets for this stuff
that you're in alignment and then i'm
not mad that she went and bought
something for stupid house because we're
in alignment on it
just like it's like being in alignment
on the budget it's the same thing
so dana that's what you guys got to do
you need to get your philosophies a
little bit more lined up and
we don't borrow money and we don't
invest money
while we got debt on the house this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramseysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth to work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
christina ellis number one best-selling
author and ramsey personality is my
co-host today our phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
it's a free call and some say the advice
is worth exactly what you pay for it
starting off this hour is gonna be
jeremy and saint paul hi jeremy welcome
to the ramsey show hey dave thanks for
taking my call i was listening to a
christian talk radio guy out of memphis
area today and he was talking about
financial planner
i called up and said hey do you know
dave ramsey because he says the sky's
not falling everything's gonna be all
right and he said well i know who he is
but i don't know if he knows bible
prophecy very good and i don't really
agree with what he's saying so i just
wanted to ask you give you a chance
respond about what do you think about
bible prophecy because he believes
there's going to be a
someday christ is coming there's gonna
be a pre-millennial
or he's gonna set up a thousand-year
kingdom but before that there's gonna be
a seven year tribulation most believers
i know
feel that we're getting close but every
time i listen you know you it's like
it's gonna go on like it always has so i
just wanted to ask you about that
okay well that's fair well obviously uh
those of us that are people of faith
that are christians um
and have studied the bible much know
that the study of end times is
eschatology right
and there are three
uh forms of thought around that pre-trib
post mid-trib and post-trib
meaning tribulation uh
and so when uh you know
when are we going to be called to heaven
before the tribulation the middle of
tribulation or after the tribulation and
depending on which one of those you
would fall into then you'd be much more
concerned about this if you're going to
be uh called to heaven instantaneously
in the air prior to the tribulation
then you would not care from a financial
planning perspective
correct
correct
yes you're the only person i know i
heard you talking and so the only per
the only people you would the only
people that would worry about it would
or that would be concerned about
financial planning during a tribulation
would be mid-tribbers or post-tribbers
does that make sense
i absolutely agree with you okay all
right cool so then once we say that then
we've got to say
uh
you know how many times
since scripture was written
have uh intelligent well-meaning people
decided that they recognized the signs
from revelation and that now we're in
the end times
you want me to tell you how many times
every freaking year
every year
i mean in 1988 a guy wrote a book 88
reasons jesus is coming back in 88
missed that one
right
and you can go through every the
and
no man will know the time or the hour
jesus said from his own mouth
okay remember that
yes sir okay and so
yes there's some interesting very uh
mind-bending and spiritual questions
that can be asked around the end times
and the study of prophecy but i'm going
to stop real short
of predicting the end times
based on the fact that a
bunches people smarter than me and that
guy who was questioning that on the
radio in memphis a bunch of people
smarter than either one of us have
missed it every single year for 2000
years
on when they thought he this was all
happening
i mean you i can show you some very
interesting studies during world war ii
that uh peop that real smart theologians
were convinced uh hitler was the
antichrist
and they had real good lineups on line
by line by line by line from revelations
all the evidence that this invasion and
this movement in the war and the
extermination of the jews and all of
that kind of stuff there was really good
evidence that that was the end times
oops missed it you are you are pre-trib
though right or
i don't think it matters for this
discussion yeah
no no the reason no my point is i'm
going to come to the same conclusion
about financial planning regardless of
whether i'm pre-med or post-trib
because in order to plan for the end
times in as a mid-trib or post-tribber
you would have to believe you can
predict them
and i'm telling you very thoroughly here
that i don't believe that
i don't believe you can tell me you're
getting hope sometimes i'm thinking it's
going to happen every day but yeah
hey and and as screwed up and toxic as
this world is come quickly lord jesus
okay amen i'm ready baby let's let's
let's call this thing it's messed up
it's sodom and gomorrah out there man it
is a screwed up bunch of human beings
out there running around they're all
over the place you don't believe me just
open up a social media account there's
some bonkers people out there
and so from a from a faith perspective
yeah i i
but but can we not look back truthfully
as intelligent human beings and say
this has happened before this has
happened in rome this has happened with
the inquisitions this has happened with
the salem witch trials this has happened
you can go back and find all kinds of
times that you look out into society and
go society is gone to hell in a hand
basket it must be a sign of the coming
of the age and it's just
you just can't predict it i don't think
and uh and i know a lot of theologians
and a lot of good friends of mine that
think they've got it dialed in but man
i'm just telling you that's that's thin
ice when you start thinking you're gonna
dial in the day
and you you got this figured out that
i mean there were people who thought
bill clinton was the antichrist i heard
a whole thing on that
and uh and he he obviously wasn't
pretty obviously if he if he is he's a
really bad one
you know and so um
poor bill
but you know you got to start naming you
know this invasion of this and this
movement of that and you have to and you
align all of that with the uh
with the with the innuendo and the hints
in revelation and it's a fun exercise to
try to do it but when you go down that
rabbit hole the thing you have to
remember is
you will be one of a bazillion people in
the last 2000 years that got this wrong
that when you start calling the end
times with certainty
so much certainty that you start
changing your financial plan and how
you're going to live your life uh then
you're about to be wrong you're about to
be wrong and so whether i believe it's
post-trib mid-trigger doesn't matter
what i believe that overshadows all of
that is that you can't predict when the
end times are and people that say that
they can are wrong
have been so far a hundred percent of
the time
they've got a hundred percent wrong
guessing game
so far now one of these days somebody's
gonna guess it and get it right but
i hadn't hadn't figured that one out yet
so not betting uh not betting my mutual
funds on that yeah so that that's where
that comes from and that's a great
discussion though jeremy thank you for
giving me the opportunity to do
something i don't get to do very often
that's fun yeah it's a good one that was
a very good analysis thanks for sharing
that yeah and it's just
but yeah yeah
there's bad stuff out there
don't get so caught up in it
and
that you you're predicting something
you're not capable of predicting
it's not within your purview
it's not within my purview either
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five
well everybody's got questions out there
and theories and feelings about real
estate the million dollar question is
what's going to happen with house prices
best way to figure that out hasn't
changed
ever
i've been doing real estate for 44 years
and the way you figure out what's going
to happen with house prices is the way
you do everything with data
not with feelings
and
data on supply demand inflation
you're looking at interest rates
and you know you then you've got a
predictive model that you can do this
with we're going to walk you through
this actual data this thursday
in our free
real estate reality check
is the real estate market going to crash
is the bubble going to burst spoiler
alert no
now i'm going to show you why and it's
free join us on this on this free live
stream
george campbell rachel cruz will join me
we're going to tell you what we think
and why in great detail it's going to be
a bit of a class a bit of an academic
approach to this and get your heads
around what's going on and then you get
to make your decision because you're
like grown-ups and stuff
and uh you can choose to not agree with
us or to agree with us and we'll still
be okay and we can even still be friends
how's that that's weird yeah so july
14th 7 p.m
central time it's free you need to
pre-sign at ramseysolutions.com
realitycheck to get on our platform and
we will deliver that puppy to you and
you'll be able to watch this and i hope
we can give you some real information
that you can analyze then maybe it'll
remove fear for some of you maybe it'll
return hope to some of you
maybe it'll give you a little different
strategy on what you're thinking about
with selling or buying a house we're
going to show you what we think we would
do and here's exactly why from a from an
intellectual perspective from a study of
economics and actual data
not a feeling
not a feeling
because there's a lot of feelings out
there a lot of feelings and most of them
are fear a lot of fear well there's so
many opinions and so many articles
coming out that say complete opposite
things and people are confused and
everything on the internet is true i
mean abraham lincoln tweeted that last
week so um
you know that so that right
[Music]
yeah ramsay solutions.com sign up for
the real estate reality check thursday
night it is a free live stream join us
blinds.com gives us our question of the
day find out for yourself why blinds.com
is the number one online retailer of
custom window coverings free samples
free shipping new promos all the time
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best possible deal
today's question comes from mike in
pennsylvania my kid is most likely not
going to college i was always taught
that everyone goes to college how do i
help him find his path
this is a good question especially in
light of so many of the discussions
we've been having recently around
college and the pressure to go to
college and take out student loans
and the borrowed future documentary
where we're exposing this toxic culture
you know so many people have been told
that you have to go to college to be
successful and that's the only way at
all cost and that's just simply not true
college is not for everyone it's a great
thing we we love education i'm a big
believer in education but it's not for
everyone but for generations it's been
told that you have to go
so mike i do understand you know the
concern about your kid not going to
college and one of the first things i
would do is work through your own
emotions around that you know try to
think through you know why do i feel
this way what kind of fear do i have
with my kid maybe not being successful
and what are your worries and concerns
settle that in yourself and then
approach your student and your child
because the thing is is it's so easy to
kind of weave your opinion in and
kind of get aggressive and then the wall
goes up and then your kid doesn't want
to talk to you about anything they don't
want to talk about the future and that
line of communication is kind of closed
so what i do want is for you to still
have that line of communication open and
really ask your kid questions about what
do they want to do and help them explore
what that future could potentially look
like set goals you know there's a lot of
different ways to get an education it's
not just the traditional four-year
degree you know maybe they go to work
doing an apprenticeship maybe they go to
trade school maybe they get a
certificate there's a lot of different
ways to get educated to have a
successful career but you want them to
be willing to talk to you and not just
shut down because they think that you
only want one thing you know keep that
line open there's so many different
options and then also it's important to
set clear boundaries you know if your
kid is potentially lazy and is thinking
i don't want to go to college because
i'm going to sit here and you know stay
at home and kind of mooch off you for
the rest of my life like that
conversation needs to happen too you
know perhaps they do stay home for a
period as they work and kind of figure
out what's next but it's important to
kind of set that boundary of like you
know maybe if you stay here you need to
pay rent or if you stay here here are
the rules but one of the biggest things
is just keeping that line of
communication open and having those
discussions
yeah but because an eagle that doesn't
leave the nest eventually is known as a
turkey so um
you know that that needs to happen but
the the other thing is this you need to
remember that
as a parent
somewhere along the line
in our culture we have slipped a gear
and um
thought that okay once they're like 17
they're completely developed and they're
allowed to do whatever they want to do
and they're really really smart because
they're young and beautiful no they're
not
they're young and dumb
and they need a mom and they need a dad
to look at them and go no that's not
smart
you know you need to tell them the truth
because you've still got more influence
even than you think you do even if they
roll their eyes you've got more
influence than you think you do now
here's what it would be at my house okay
100 of you
that leave this house
need to plan on a life-long
pursuit of learning
if you don't keep learning
you're dying
if the last time you read a non-fiction
book was 15 years ago you got a problem
if the last time you ever took any kind
of a class of any kind
was a decade ago you got a problem
i teach classes for a living and i take
classes
i read books like crazy that are
non-fiction and fiction
and so uh constantly have a book open
uh you know and so
i'm gonna tell junior i don't know why
you're saying he's not going to school i
don't know what why why you've come to
that conclusion but
not going to a four-year school that's
fine but you're gonna do something
you're gonna engage in some kind of a
cert program some kind of a trade school
program uh some kind of a
uh code school whatever it is you're
gonna do you're gonna you need to do
something post high school because
you're going to be at a
vast disadvantage your probability of
poverty goes way up unless you engage in
a lifetime of learning and it starts
with what your first post-high school
decision is now again you won't be a
diesel mechanic i'm good with that i
know diesel mechanics making over 100k
and they love working they love working
in the grease and they love turning the
wrench and they're good at it and they
they they're you know they're engine
whisperers they can do it man i love
them and you want to do that that's cool
go do that you'll make more than
somebody who gets a sociology degree
with masters okay so have at it i'm good
with that but the uh
the idea that you get to do nothing post
high school that's not even on the
table and as his dad uh you need to
influence him starting now on that
and so okay we gonna do something bubba
what is it what is it we gonna do okay
game on all right and that's what you
need to do here and plug into that
that's going to be a big deal
and uh and as you said college isn't for
everyone uh and you know you did post
graduate work i didn't uh i did some
postgraduate work i didn't complete a
postgraduate degree you did but um the
uh
you know the idea that somehow okay i i
i wrote an app and i made a million
dollars and i'm 19. doesn't mean you're
done bubba it means you just got started
and you got a really good start but if
you think you're going to keep doing
that over and over and over again for
the rest of your life with absolutely no
training
not happening you got lucky and fell
backward into that one and so you need
to you need to figure out a way to
replicate this and usually that involves
some form of education
now i'll hire people in the technology
field all day long who don't have a
four-year degree but have all the certs
and they've been to code school and they
can write code and they know what
they're doing most of the best ones
don't have a four-year degree in that
so and we got 300 400 tech folk in the
building you know we got coders and uh
engineers software engineers all over
the building and hiring them every day
we love them and i don't that four-year
degree is not necessary there but i
really don't want you doing my
accounting as my cfo if you don't have a
four-year degree in that
because that's pretty basic stuff
you know and so you've got to decide
what the training is for the career
direction you want to go continuous
lifetime of learning
that you need to demand
regardless of what little child boy
wants to do here we're going we're going
we're going to lay out some other stuff
here that's going to be the plan this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones at eight eight
two five five two two five maui hawaii
is on the line jennifer is calling says
on my screen you're debt free jennifer
way to go
thank you so much dave it is such an
honor to talk with you you too how much
did you pay off
365
000.
how long did that take
it took me i can't believe it still when
i say it three years in four months
whoa
and your range of income during that
time
well i'm a special ed teacher and so
initially my income was 53 000 after
taxes and i doubled my income up to 110k
okay
and how'd you double your income as a
special ed teacher
i know right um so i
took on 13 actually maybe 14 extra side
gigs um
yeah what was the most lucrative one
what's the one that made you the most
money
well i actually um
i think it would be renting out the
three bedrooms in my home sharing my
space with other people of course being
a landlord is definitely lucrative it's
awesome
yes it was a massive change in my
lifestyle but i just knew that i laid
down the math and i said you know what i
can just do this if i can just have this
lifestyle for just three years i can be
done
you didn't make
365 000 in three years so where did you
get the rest of it
okay so i also did online english i was
an english tutor online for
a company that actually you suggested um
for uh kids in china so i tutored them
and i pulled in about 50 hours a week
doing that so if i basically wasn't
sleeping i was working for three years
i'm sorry so that but still 110 times
three
is 3 30.
well i also did i ran a cat hotel in my
home so
you made more than 110
no no um so these it was it was it was
up to 110 um and three years so 365 and
three years i don't know i made it
happen with 14 jobs
um you didn't make it 110 times 3 that's
3 30.
3 30. i must have had some money well i
didn't get any inheritances no handouts
okay so i might have had some extra
money that i might have pulled out from
my
growing emergency fund to make it to pat
it in there okay cool all right yeah all
right i'm just trying to get there all
the math because and also you had to eat
during that time
yes yeah okay
well it was also um meal prepping for i
kind of think you made more than you
thought you made
possibly possibly you're working so much
you forgot to count it yeah
it's possible
way to go this is pretty amazing yeah
yeah so what happened that got you
started on this journey
well it this is all a house um i got
divorced
and there's nothing that sets you into a
sense of reality than going from
two-person income to a one-person income
and i bought out my ex-husband on the
marital home and so that's when i
realized i needed to just i didn't want
to be you know in debt and i wanted to
you know have a place where i could take
care of myself financially and not worry
in the future
so this is house and everything you paid
off
yes so i was debt-free always always
kind of had that lifestyle of debt free
and it's funny because um when i did the
buyout process so this is the price of
half of a house on maui so the house
value at the time of the divorce was
about
700 000 in change and so half of the
house value was 365. oh so this was all
about buying him out or paying off the
loan from buying him out
correct yeah okay wow
so now you own a three quarters of a
million dollar more than that it's
probably worth 800 or 900 now right
it's at 1.2
and it's 100 yours
it is all mine and i'm telling you like
i i know you say that the grass is going
to feel different under your feet and it
it really does but i do want to say just
it really
you got no matter what you do in this
process
there's a little bit of dissonance in my
my joy right now that it's finished it's
kind of like
there was so much joy to the effort
process while i was doing this it was
quite liberating to know that i was on
the right path and i feel like sometimes
when you know that you're on the right
path sometimes that's the reward
and um
yeah it's just
you gotta get ready for that you know
when you have a big goal you do the debt
free scream and i'm so grateful to be on
the air but there's also a message out
to people that are doing this that
you know just get ready for that feeling
of like well now what you know um and
and if you attach joy to the effort
process while you're in there
accomplishing your goal i think
you're just gonna you realize you're
practicing self-love you realize you're
doing the right thing that needs to be
done for your future
and you know i think that in itself is
the reward that people should really
focus on and just have fun it's about
you know you're doing the right thing
for yourself have fun in the process and
and really
look at what you're doing for your
future for your children's future for
your kids or or you know just just you
per se so
um that's just kind of my biggest take
home with all of this is um and i don't
hear that enough you know just in
general um but i see the excitement of
all the people that have supported me
and people that are also doing the same
thing we're just so excited like i just
did an extra 5k towards my mortgage
you're like way to go you know that's
that is joy right there and that's what
kept me going the whole time and i'm
gonna miss that you know i'm really
gonna miss the the support from people
as well so there's joy in both traction
and in struggle
and that's what you're saying and you
know we forget that uh we live in a
culture who tries to create comfort
and safe places
in all of this and and you're actually
much better
at life when you can uh engage the
challenge and you're right there's more
fun to it
uh you know if you don't engage a
challenge there's not as much joy i
agree with you completely embrace the
embrace the suck this some of this stuff
sucks and you just gotta lean into it
and you just embrace it and go with it
and it is
it is and and we can we've both been
there too and so we can you know
kind of completely we're both sitting
here agreeing with you and also uh
experiencing the same thing again just
watching you do it well done
yeah and you mentioned
you mentioned cheering when when 5000
was paid off that people were cheering
for you who are your biggest
cheerleaders in this process
i have to say it's crazy but it's
strangers and here's another thing that
is common probably for a lot of people
that the people closest to them don't
understand you know your family might be
like what are you doing who are you to
say that you're going to be owning a you
know multi-million dollar home on maui
as a single woman like what you know
sometimes the family doesn't understand
some of my family's members were
supportive others just didn't understand
and then some people closest to me my
closest friends were like you're gonna
do what so um i felt i reached out
online and found these informal support
groups of people that are paying down
the mortgage on social media
and i gotta say they were the ones that
kept me going i already had the mindset
to be debt-free it was always my
lifestyle my family my parents were also
debt-free growing up but when you know
my life goes sideways in a divorce i
knew what i had to do
but it wasn't as lonely in the process
you know now i'm alone in life and i
felt that way but i didn't feel alone in
the process of building up um you know
paying off the mortgage and it was it
was through those facebook groups
tremendous power in community that's
beautiful
hey we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you in this process you
became one i'm so proud of you
and a copy of a total money makeover for
you to give away and someone that's
caught up in your enthusiasm wake here
they're gonna they're gonna bold over
and they're gonna want to start also
financial peace university membership
for a year all of that we're going to
send to you we're so proud of you
jennifer well done
thank you thank you so much guys 365 000
paid off in three years in four months
making 53 to 110 or more count it down
let's hear a dead free scream
three two one
[Applause]
that is how it's done
beautiful
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day hebrews 10 35
and 36 so do not throw away your
confidence it will be richly rewarded
you need to persevere so that when you
have done the will of god you will
receive what he has promised
james crook said a man who wants to lead
the orchestra must turn his back
on the crowd
christina alice ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
jake is next in murray kentucky hi jake
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave thanks so much for taking my
call it's an honor honor to talk to you
i i just want
yeah well thank you i was going to say
just real quick i actually wrote a book
about eschatology and you were spot on
with the first caller i i enjoyed
hearing your answer to that
honor and thank you
yeah so so my question is uh my wife and
i just sold we closed in our house last
week uh we were able to we had enough
equity that we're we're on baby step
seven now so we just bought a house debt
free
uh
glory to be the guide uh we're gonna
have when when everything clears and we
get all the renovations done we're gonna
have about a hundred thousand dollars
left over
and uh i'm in the teacher's retirement
and so we're kind of behind on
retirement a little bit and i was
curious if there's a way to take that
money and do like a backdoor roth ira
like go into an ira in the backdoor it
or what what you suggest to do with that
uh well you don't need to do a backdoor
eye or a roth unless you make over two
hundred thousand dollars a year
household income do you
um no no i do not okay then you can only
do regular roths and that would be all
you would need the back door is a method
for someone with higher income to still
get their money into a roth that's all
it is but it's the same amount it's not
an additional roth it's still the same
you know
same number of dollars going into your
retirement so that that's not going to
fix it so basically you've got a hundred
thousand dollars to invest in your 100
debt free is that what i'm hearing
yes sir yes sir absolutely well uh what
we always try to do is three things at
the ramsey house we want to enjoy some
of it be generous with some of it
and earmark a certain amount and then be
done with it and also the third thing is
to be investing some of it now on the
portion that you're investing
what i do at baby step 7 is two things i
either buy real estate that i pay cash
for
um or i put it in good growth stock
mutual funds
if you're going to do the second one
which is probably more likely because
you don't have three hundred thousand
you've got a hundred thousand
um you could buy a nice little house
maybe in murray kentucky for that uh
that would be a rental if you wanted to
if that's the business you want to get
into or if you want to fool with that
stuff if you don't
then you would buy a mutual fund that
has what's called a low
turnover ratio
and what that means is the mutual fund
does not sell the stocks inside the
mutual fund hardly at all they don't
turn over much
okay so you're looking for something
that has like five percent turnover
ratio and what that means is 95 of the
stocks inside the mutual fund are not
sold every year they sit there why is
that important because you're only taxed
in a mutual fund on what you take out or
what they sell
inside and so if they sell a hundred
percent of it every year they had a
hundred percent turnover ratio which
some of them have a 200 turnover ratio
but if they sell all the stocks and roll
them over every year 100 of the gains
are taxable every year
if they're not selling them with a low
turnover ratio it's not taxed until you
sell it so it works like this if you buy
a share of stock let's just make it up a
home depot okay and you bought it for
fifty dollars i don't even know what
home depot sells for but if you bought
it for fifty dollars a share and it goes
up to seventy dollars a share you do not
pay taxes on the twenty dollar gain
until you sell it
does that make sense so as long as you
don't sell that stock and it just grows
and grows and grows and grows and grows
all that capital gains growth
is
realized but you don't recognize it for
tax purposes until you sell it
and so capital gains growth like that is
is
is in a sense tax deferred growth
and so a low turnover mutual fund is a
whole bunch of stocks in there that
aren't being sold and so you're not
paying taxes on the growth
until you sell it if you hold it more
than one year it's going to be taxed at
capital gains rate 15 rather than at
your ordinary income rate of 30
so that's even better
so it's a low tax when you do pay it
and no tax until you cash it out
an easy way to find a low turnover
mutual fund is just holler at one of our
smartvestor pros they can help you pick
one out or even easier than that you
just buy a no load s p 500 index fund
most of those have a three or four
percent turnover ratio
like a vanguard or a fidelity or
whatever somebody like that
and just just buy you an index 500
mutual fund because what they're doing
is matching the index so they hardly
ever sell the stocks they just buy the
index and hold them and then whatever
that group of stocks does that top 500
stocks does is what you're gonna have
you're gonna have a 10 12 rate of return
on that with no taxes at all until you
sell it or virtually no taxes until you
sell so low turnover ratio of course the
same thing happens with real estate you
can buy that little rental house for 100
000 it goes up to 200 000 in value you
don't pay taxes on that gain
until you sell it
so again you've got tax deferred or
capital gains type
growth
and and that's what some of these idiots
are referring to when they say things
like uh
you know rich people don't pay taxes the
secretary warren buffett pays more in
taxes no she doesn't pay more in taxes
she pays a higher percentage of her
income in taxes because she's paying
income tax not capital gains tax
and if you live off of this type of
investment
you live off of capital gains
because you built wealth
and so it's just good planning it's not
it's not like the tax system is broken
or something or somehow rich people are
getting a break and poor people aren't
getting a break believe me rich people
pay stinking taxes i mean there's a lot
of years in my life i would trade my
income for the taxes i pay a year now a
lot of years
and so uh you know you don't get out of
paying taxes on your income but when
you've got investment income that's
growing this way it's virtually or it's
tax deferred and it's then taxed
somewhat
uh tax favored
it's awesome that's good motivation to
keep investing that's incredible moves
in that direction eric's with us in
champaign illinois hi eric welcome to
the ramsey show
hi christie and dave i hope you guys are
well great how can we help
so um let me just say i'm horrible with
money i'm bad with money i have no idea
how to manage it four years ago i traded
in a car i was upside down on
and uh for
another new car two years later i
refinanced it well i owe 19 000 on it
and just for curiosity i took it to the
dealership over the weekend to see how
much they'd give to me they
said they gave me twenty eight thousand
dollars for it so
i mean that's a nice healthy profit
would it be a good idea for me to just
go ahead and sell that back to
the dealership take that money by some
sort of a used car
and you know get just get rid of that
debt or should i just spend the next
three years because i know it's a
reliable reliable vehicle
and try to pay it off over the course of
the next three years
i mean if you do that now you could
still have nine thousand dollars to buy
a used car is that right
even uh yes yeah
i mean if i were in your shoes that's
what i would do i would sell it back to
the dealer and then go get a nine
thousand dollar car
and get rid of that debt
instantly what do you make
uh about 60. okay that's what i would do
okay yeah and here's here's the thing
though listen that absolutely will not
work
until you start handling money
and stop buying cars on payments
if this is the last one forever and ever
amen you changed your life with this
transaction
if this is just a move you make until
you impulse again
then this was just a you know we were
just spinning our wheels we're just
being a rat and wheel then i don't want
you to do that okay
okay this is this first step of you
completely changing your life and never
say out loud again i'm stupid with money
because i'm about to teach you about
money okay i'm gonna put you through
financial peace university you're gonna
be a freaking expert when you're done if
you'll go take this class and i'm gonna
give it to you okay
are you are you serious i'm dead serious
but you gotta go take the class if i
give it to you
i will i i certainly will okay and now
when you're a millionaire you go buy
this from some guy who says he doesn't
know how to handle money okay
oh i i so i'll buy it for 10 people
who's i'll buy it for 100 people don't
over promise calm down just calm down
right now what i want you to do is go to
class and get out of debt okay and get
and get your competence up and your
confidence up so you never go in debt
again now that puts a stake in the
ground when you sell this car and in
that case i'd sell the car eric well
done christina that puts this hour of
the ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you